bonjour bonjour et leur a dit merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et de notre
invité politique ce matin vous êtes des
frites et du secrétaire général des
républicains et on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par votre presse quotidienne aurélien
pradié c'est christelle bertrand du
groupe la dépêche bonjour christelle
jour rien mon jour est bien la jouer oui
la preuve on va commencer en parlant
évidemment de la crise sanitaire la
cinquième vague qui est là et bien là le
vario mikron qui inquiète et galeries à
la tall qui dit qu'il n'est pas prévu de
changer les règles d'ici noël est ce que
le gouvernement a raison de ne pas
durcir les restrictions d'ici là vous
m'avez entendu dire déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines que le grand défi que
nous avions à relever désormais c'était
autant le défi la préservation de la
santé de nos concitoyens qu'une priorité
absolue mais aussi la préservation de la
liberté dans notre pays et je sais que
ça paraît toujours un peu distant des
réalités de traiter cette question là
mais on peut pas continuellement vivre
dans une société qui prive de liberté
nos concitoyens et je pense que c'est le
moment et compris pour des députés de
poser ces questions-là et donc pour vous
répondre très clairement je suis
défavorable à ce qu'on durcisse à
nouveau les règles parce que nous
commençons à voir les impacts très fort
que tout cela dans la société sur la vie
sociale qui n'est pas un détail qui tue
quelque chose de très profond qui aura
des conséquences durables y compris sur
la santé psychique de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens est donc temps que nous
pourrons proposer à nos concitoyens de
faire preuve de responsabilité
je pense que ne pas durcir les règles
c'est aussi faire confiance à nos
concitoyens et on a peut-être oublié
cela mais il est temps désormais de
considérer que la responsabilité
individuelle c'est la meilleure manière
d'élever les citoyens donc
responsabilité individuelle ça veut dire
ça veut dire vaccination par exemple
saveurs sable c'est être vaccinés ça
veut dire vaccination où m'avez toujours
entendu défendre la vaccination la plus
large possible
c'est la responsabilité respecter des
gestes barrières mais l'encours juillet
les contaminations record des taux qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis des mois parce
qu'on a tous relâchait les gestes
barrière à ce que tu complot miser
uniquement sur la responsabilité des
citoyens eh bien je pense qu'on était un
vrai tournant d'un débat profondément
politique c'est un vrai sujet qu'on ne
doit pas à balayer d'un revers de la
main depuis plusieurs mois nous avons
expliqué à nos concitoyens on nous a
expliqué ce qu'on devait faire
quotidiennement or en découvrons nous
explique même comment on doit se laver
les mains alors je sais que ça paraît
tout ça secondaire enfin je considère
qu'on est assez grand pour savoir
comment se laver les mains et ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que sortie de cette
infantilisation permanente de la société
on risque d'avoir fabriqué des robots
plus que des citoyens et je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit une bonne nouvelle non
seulement pour notre démocratie et en
plus je suis pas sur soi une bonne
nouvelle pour la santé publique parce
que la santé publique elle est puissante
elle est forte lorsqu'elle s'appuie sur
la responsabilité individuelle et je
pense qu'il est temps à nouveau de faire
confiance à la responsabilité
individuelle
de manipulation j'ai dénoncé à la
tribune de l'assemblée nationale il n'ya
presque mois un risque grave qui est
celui de l'accoutumance
l'accoutumance aux privations de liberté
l'accoutumance à un régime démocratique
dégradé le régime de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est un régime démocratique
dégradée en qu'elle le parlement
fonctionne mal trop mal et une
accoutumance sûrement à
l'infantilisation nos concitoyens oui je
pense que l'accoutumance c'est
aujourd'hui un vrai sujet politique
alors comment faire pour l'éviter ça
veut dire on laisse faire les gens on
arrête les restrictions et non on laisse
pas faire les gens d'abord on pousse à
la vaccination je le dis je leur ai même
des enfants pour le coup j'ai une
réserve sur les enfants je vous en dirai
un mot mais je pense aussi qu'il faut
tirer les enseignements du début la
crise sanitaire et notamment réarmer nos
services de soins réarmer notre hôpital
quelques jours des hôpitaux c'est on a
du mal à recruter parce que les gens
sont pas formés aujourd'hui non
seulement le recrutement mais le
réarmement notamment des lits d'urgence
enfin c'était invraisemblable nous avons
déjà oublié que le gouvernement dès la
première crise sanitaire avait promis de
réarmer des lits d'urgence on n'a pas
aujourd'hui un dixième lits d'urgence
qui nous avait été promis qu'ils ont été
réouverts beaucoup d'autres pays
d'europe et du monde ont été capables en
l'espace de deux mois de réouvrir des
services entiers d'urgence avec des
professionnels qui ont été formés
spécifiquement sur ces cas là il ya des
pays d europe plus long que ça le temps
de former les gens non ça c'est faux
d'abord depuis qu'on le dit on aurait eu
le temps d'informer ensuite on est
capable sur des pathologies bien
particulière qui sont celles liées à la
coved dont on connaît les techniques
aujourd'hui lie à l'oxygénothérapie etc
etc de forme et très rapidement des
professionnels en techniques avancées en
espace de quelques mois on est capable
de le faire il s'agit pas de former des
urgentistes généraliste en l'espace de
six mois mais de les former
spécifiquement sur l'urgence que nous
avons qui locaux vides enfin depuis deux
ans on aurait largement eu le temps de
réaliser tout cela et le gouvernement ne
l'a pas fait et de lorsque nous les
républicains nous proposons de réarmer
les services d'urgence y compris de
manière provisoire nous le disons depuis
deux ans philippe juvin nos proches le
dis depuis deux ans ça n'a toujours pas
été fait voilà une solution que nous
mettons sur la table trois années mot là
dessus je sais sur la vaccination des
enfants du coup elle débute aujourd'hui
pour les plus fragiles est ce que vous
êtes favorable à sa généralisation pour
les 5 11 ans sous réserve bien
évidemment de la validation des
autorités sanitaires n'ont aujourd'hui
je n'y suis pas favorable je suis
langage comeau en le disant pour une
raison très simple c'est que nous
n'avons pas assez de recul scientifique
et les spécialistes le disent d'ailleurs
sur des publics âgé depuis 12 ans nous
avons un vrai recul parce qu'on a dans
le monde mac signer massivement et donc
on a forcément des tests grandeur nature
pour dire les choses simplement sur les
enfants ce n'est pas le cas les seuls
qui le font massivement aujourd'hui sont
les américains on aura un recul dans
quelques mois et je pense qu'il faut
attendre d'avoir ce recul là vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui la vaccination peut avoir
des effets secondaires qui sont
marginaux sur le public adulte mais on
sait scientifiquement que plus le public
est jeune plus les effets secondaires
sont importants notamment sur le coeur
et je pense qu'il faut avoir cette
réserve la cette prudence là c'est
pourquoi je ne suis pas favorable à la
généralisation de la vaccination tout en
état de santé mais aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas et donc il n'est pas question
tant que la haute autorité de santé n'a
pas donné son feu vert que nous le
fassions et je souhaiterais au delà
d'avoir le feu vert de la haute autorité
de santé que nous attendions d'avoir le
recul nécessaire sur les vaccinations en
population générale qui se font
d'ailleurs je pense que la prudence
c'est aussi une exigence de santé
publique et voilà la raison pour
laquelle j'y suis défavorable
j'ajoute à cela que on ne peut pas
lancer de grandes campagnes de santé
publique avec une défiance qui plane et
nous avons sur la vaccination des
enfants une défiance qui plane et donc
je pense que ce serait une mauvaise idée
du coup on attend combien de temps on
attend d'avoir le recul nécessaire ça
peut durer plusieurs mois si c'est
encore plus long et bien nous ne le
ferons pas c'est la proposition que je
formule aujourd'hui d'autant que le vrai
sujet c'est d'aller au maximum de la
vaccination sur les plus de 12 ans avant
de s'intéresser aux moins de 12 ans
intéressons-nous déjà à ceux qui ne sont
pas encore vaccinés parce qu'ils n'ont
pas confiance et que l'on doit écouter
et entendre et qu'ils ont plus de 12 ans
on va parler de l'intervention des
manuels là qu'on se soit reconstruit un
peu de politique emmanuel macron sera à
la télévision ce soir pendant deux
heures pour défendre notamment son bilan
est-ce que de votre point de vue il est
dans son rôle de président de la
république d'abord deux heures c'est
long je souhaite bonne chance à tous
ceux qui vont l'écouter durant deux
heures mais cinq ans c'est long
donc je n'écouterai pas deux heures non
c'est une certitude
emmanuel macron me fatigue et d'ailleurs
je crois qu'il fatigue les français et
je crois que depuis cinq ans il a
fatigués les français et ses exercices
narcissique de ce président qui ne s'est
jamais rien dire brièvement qui a besoin
de s'étaler comme la confiture sur la
tartine c'est devenu insupportable je le
dis comme je le pense je pense que
emmanuel macron est un président qui
fatiguent les français une conférence de
presse une émission quasiment la même
semaine c'était trop c'est beaucoup
entre les cas ça montre une chose c'est
qu'il a la trouille et qu'il a tout
simplement la trouille il a la trouille
de valérie pécresse il a la trouille
d'avoir aujourd'hui en face de lui une
véritable concurrente j'ajoute à ça que
je trouve que c'est très inélégant alors
je sais que la politique ce n'est pas
qu'une affaire d'élégance mais pour moi
c'est une attitude de petits mecs je
vous dise les choses comme je les pense
quand on programme en urgence une
émission de deux heures alors qu'on sait
que sa concurrente valérie pécresse a
déjà une émission politique programmée
le même jour c'est une c'est un
comportement de petit mec c'est pas un
comportement de président de la
république c'est pas un comportement de
campagne électorale tout simplement
c'est un comportement de petit mec en
campagne électorale sûrement qui a la
trouille mais pas un comportement de
président de la république j'essayais
l'aurais pas fait la même chose si ça
avait été quelqu'un d'autre que valérie
pécresse si ça avait été un homme par
exemple est ce que ça change les choses
pour vous présenter à un public que
valérie pécresse a une femme et que ça
soit votre candidat j'espère que non
j'espère que emmanuel macron dans son
grand élan de modernité en attend plus
des relents misogyne non-jeu j'imagine
que non je n'ose pas y croire ce que je
sais simplement c'est que la candidature
de valérie pécresse est une très bonne
nouvelle pour les républicains une très
bonne nouvelle pour les français pour la
france est une très mauvaise nouvelle
pour la macro ni ça c'est une certitude
on va y revenir mais valérie pécresse
qui veut donc saisir le csa comme
d'autres leaders de l'opposition est-ce
qu'il ya quand même pas un peu de
mauvaise foi nicolas sarkozy avait fait
la même chose il s'était déclaré très
tard il avait fait des émissions télé à
quelques semaines de la présidentielle
nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il avait fait une
émission de télé à quelques semaines de
la présidentielle comme vous le dites
avait vu son temps de parole politique
de 40 bénévoles des comptes et par le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
mais on ne savons pas aujourd'hui nous
ne connaissez vous faire confiance au
csa pour décompter comme vous et moi je
fais confiance à tout le monde mais je
pense que c'est bien de les alerter de
temps en temps le csa aurait pu se
saisir de lui même que nous n'ayons pas
besoin de le faire en tous les cas
aujourd'hui c'est fait il faut que le
csa fixe la règle pour ce qui est du
temps de parole de campagne électorale
vous parlez de bilan il va défendre son
bilan il n'y a pas besoin de deux heures
pour défendre le bilan des manuels
maquereau en quelques minutes
suffiraient largement quand il est vide
mais sur ce temps là ça doit être
décompté écouter situe encore
règles démocratiques de base emmanuel
macron n'est pas au dessus des règles
n'est pas au dessus des règles du temps
de parole il faut qu'il y ait une équité
c'est aussi ça le principe de démocratie
pour que nos classes et riad lui
suggérer qu'il équitable avec tous les
candidats il a commencé à décompter le
temps d'eric zemmour avant qu'il soit
candidat donc il ya bien le csa n'a plus
qu'à confirmer que sur les deux heures
de palabres d' emmanuel macron tout ce
qui relève aura de la campagne
électorale sera décompté de son temps de
parole et dans ces cas-là l'équité sera
sauf à la laiterie de la majorité
présidentielle des cas une forme
d'obsession des manies macron chez les
républicains et chez valérie pécresse
est ce que quelque part ça vous arrange
pas d'installer ce match entre valérie
pécresse et emmanuel macron le match il
peut entre l'un et l'autre valérie
pécresse et nous sommes candidats pour
redresser la france
ce qui nous intéresse c'est de parler
aux français on n'est pas là dans de la
politicaille le sujet c'est pas emmanuel
macron le sujet c'est l'avenir de notre
pays et nous pensons que l'avenir de
notre pays ne peut plus passer par
emmanuel macron qu'il a trop habillé la
france qu'il faut désormais remettre de
l'ordre dans le pays et redonner un
espoir à nos concitoyens et nous pensons
que la droite républicaine à cette
responsabilité particulière la gauche ne
peut pas le faire elle est aujourd'hui
totalement
inexistante elle a disparu de la
circulation emmanuel macron a trop menti
aux français pour le faire c'était la
droite républicaine de le faire et à
valérie pécresse notre seule obsession
c'est pas emmanuel macron notre seule
obsession c'est la france et les
français n'oubliez pas un petit peu
marine le pen exe mois dans votre
inscription je pense que j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu les mentionner mais je le
redis pour nous on n'est pas là en train
d'installer le match avec les uns et les
autres ce que l'on veut c'est installe
le dialogue avec les français pour
demain une gagner la présidentielle pas
pour nous pas pour l'intérêt des
républicains tout ça est secondaire mais
pour l'intérêt de la france notre parti
c'est la france et c'est ce qui compte
c'est ce qui comptera dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent alors vous
parlez d'installer le dialogue certains
chez vous s'inquiètent déjà d'un
syndrome anne hidalgo avec valérie
pécresse en dix ans elle parle aux zones
urbaines elle parle aux métrople ça va
être plus compliqué avec les zones
rurales que vous connaissez bien qu'est
ce que vous en pensez est-ce qu' elle
n'est pas un peu trop parisienne pour
parler à l'ensemble du pays vous
conviendrez que pour arriver au syndrome
anne hidalgo on a quand même encore
besoin de faire beaucoup d'erreurs et on
n'en est pas là nono valérie pécresse
est une très bonne candidate et je vais
vous dire en deux mots pourquoi elle est
urbaine peut-être elle est présidente de
la première région d'europe
l'ile-de-france sûrement mais valérie
pécresse est une chiraquienne elle
connaît parfaitement les territoires
ruraux et puis alors à autour d'elle des
femmes et des hommes qui connaissent
parfaitement les territoires où ce qui
compte c'est pas savoir si on est urbain
aussi en et rural ce qui compte c'est de
connaître la france et valérie pécresse
et un parcours qui fait qu'elle connaît
la france qu'elle connaît autant la
france urbaine que la france rurale et
nous avons besoin des deux pour rebâtir
notre pays nous avons autant besoin des
métropoles que des territoires le
chirurgien suffit à connaître la france
ça suffit pas mais ça fait déjà beaucoup
et le parcours qui est celui de valérie
pécresse et un parcours profondément
ancrées je ne crois pas qu'on devienne
président de la république par hasard et
d'ailleurs lorsque c'est arrivé mais
nous avons vu les dégâts pour connaître
pour caunes pour réussir à être
présidente de la république ou président
de la république il faut connaître
profondément la france et dans son
parcours qui est un parcours ancrée
valérie pécresse elle a appris à
connaître la france elle sera dans le
lot dans quelques semaines pour parler
de ruralité de désertification médicale
dans jeu de ces territoires qui sont des
territoires magnifique qui sont une
chance pour la france qui sont les
territoires ruraux je serais très
heureux de l'accueillir dans le lot et
vous verrez quelle sera la candidate de
tous les territoires de notre elle parle
à tous les français parce que gérald
darmanin dimanche au grand gêneraient
ils disaient valérie pécresse elle parle
à versailles mais parlement aux
électeurs de tourcoing chez lui est ce
qu il a raison
gérald darmanin était très heureux il ya
quelques années d'accueillir valérie
pécresse pour le soutenir dans sa bonne
ville de tourcoing on voit bien gérald
darmanin c'est devenu leur hockey de la
macro ni la réalité c'est que les
répèterai ce n'est pas ni versaillaise
ni rural elle est française profondément
française et je vous assure les français
ne s'y trompent pas d'ailleurs on voit
les premières dynamique il faut être
prudent mais les premières dynamique
disent bien que les français voient en
valérie pécresse un visage de confiance
de fermeté mais aussi de confiance tous
les joueurs d'emmanuel maquereau dans le
ce matin dans le figaro clément bonne le
secrétaire aux affaires européennes il
attaque également votre candidat de
pécresse est condamné à faire du mauvais
macron du méchant se tisse sa tribune
sur l'europe est un plagiat raté la
droite est dans une course obsessionnel
avec l'extrême droite dit-il qu'est ce
que vous dites de sa d'écouté jeudi que
ce ministre là où sous secrétaire d'état
je sais pas ce qu'il y ait des deux
d'ailleurs devrait s'occuper un peu des
affaires européennes ce serait pas mal
non plutôt que d'aller faire les chiens
d'attac de la macro ni comme il le fait
avec le ministre de l'intérieur enfin
c'est fou on a un gouvernement qui n'a
jamais aussi terriblement échoué sur
tous les sujets on a quelques sujets
européens aujourd'hui monsieur bonne
devra aller s'occuper de la question des
pêcheurs par exemple parler des sujets
qui sont des sujets d'intérêt général si
désormais les membres de ce gouvernement
sont condamnés à faire de la
politicaille c'est que vraiment il est
temps de les remplacer alors nous des
écueils qui va se poser à valérie
pécresse est de réconcilier ce qu'elle a
elle même théorisé comme étant de droite
irréconciliables et et qui sont les deux
droites qui anime aujourd'hui les
républicains est ce que ça vous paraît
possible de réconcilier une droite
modérée et par exemple à droite d'eric
ciotti on a l'impression que dès le
lendemain de l'élection d'eric de
valérie pécresse pardon il ya eu
quelques tiraillements est ce que ces
tiraillements vos pas et risquent pas
d'égréner la campagne vous savez nous
avons connu suffisamment nos moments de
division pour que je vous dise
aujourd'hui que nous sommes dans une
demande d'unité faire observer on nous
allions le betting de la mutualité tout
le monde était réuni tout le monde
aujourd'hui primaires ça non c'est un
effet de prises de conscience de la
droite qui a compris qu'elle ne
gagnerait pas si elle n'était pas
rassemblé aujourd'hui ne manque personne
à l'appel personnes ça nous est parié
depuis très très très longtemps et le
fait que nous soyons rassemblés qu'on
est une équipe de france est la
meilleure manière de convaincre les
français mais pour répondre à votre
question la seule droite que je connais
ce que nous connaissions c'est la droite
républicaine si celle qui est capable
d'être fermes et déterminés sur les
valeurs républicaines on ne transige pas
avec la laïcité on ne transige pas avec
les valeurs républicaines partout en
france mais on est capable de tendre la
main on est capable de faire du mérite
de l'ascenseur social une obsession pour
notre pays et c'est cette droite
française que pour ma part j'ai toujours
défendu celle qui tend la main aux plus
fragiles pour le handicap pour les
violences conjugales celle qui est
capable de dire à un gamin du lot comme
un gamin d'aulnay-sous-bois que s'il
respecte les valeurs de la république
s'il travaille alors il pourra réussir
il faut que demain la droite française
devienne une promesse est pas une
punition et valérie pécresse a compris
cela elle l'a compris et elle le fera et
ce rassemblement cette équipe de france
que nous formerons demain autour d'elle
président de la république c'est ce qui
permettra aux français de retrouver le
sens de la république de l'autorité mais
aussi l'espoir
a compris cela parce que là vous faites
vite et en même temps dit valérie
pécresse a compris mais ce qu'eric
ciotti lui le comprend eric ciotti
quelques même région qu'ils essayent de
tirer quand même les lignes vers lui il
est trop intelligent pour ne pas
comprendre que la droite elle doit être
une espérance qu elle doit être une
promesse mais toute notre histoire est
faite de ceux là toute l'histoire de la
droite française est faite de cela à
l'effet d'autorité mais les fait aussi
des grands combats sur le handicap porté
par jacques chirac des grands combats
sur l'ascension sociale je vais vous
faire une observation en 1995 jacques
chirac est très ferme sur les questions
d'immigration mais ils gagnent sur la
fracture sociale en 2007 nicolas sarkozy
est très ferme sur les questions
d'autorité mais ils gagnent sur le
travailler plus pour gagner plus la
droite française elle est belle quand
elle est capable de dire à ses
concitoyens vous réussirez si vous le
méritez et de tendre la main aux plus
fragiles qui ont des accidents de la vie
si cela que emmanuel macron est
incapable de faire être juste et c'est
l'obsession anti eric ciotti dit ce doit
être sur mon programme c'est surtout mon
programme qu'on va gagner et donc on
suit là c'est sur le programme de
valérie pécresse c'est sur le programme
de la droite française quand même aller
regarder vers le centre droit est ce que
le centre-droit il n'est pas parti chez
mm macro et chez edouard philippe qu'il
se renforce je les trahir qui va
fusionner aujourd'hui avec son parti est
ce que ce renforcement du sens prenois
du côté de la majorité présidentielle ça
vous inquiète don et dans ce film ne
m'inquiète pas du tout c'était le
dernier wagon de la macro dit il s'agite
un peu aujourd'hui tout ça n'est pas
très grave c'est même assez assez
épisodique moi je refuse que nous
parlions au français comme à des
catégories vous savez ces sept cette
méthode des parts de marché lectorale
qui a été terrible y compris pour la
droite depuis quelques années faut que
nous parlions à tous les français tous
les français sans regarder ni leur
couleur de peau ni leur prénom ni leur
étiquette politique il faut que nous
rassemblions les français et c'est ce
qui permettra au tour de nos valeurs de
gagner demeure non pas pour nous je le
redis mais pour la france jusqu'à un
dernier mot vous n'avez dit vous avez
dit tout à l'heure il ne manque personne
il en manque un quand même c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui pour le moment refusé
d'exprimer clairement son soutien à
valérie pécresse alors ça est une figure
tutélaire pour la droite est ce que vous
regrettez ce silence de l'ancien chef de
l'état nicolas sarkozy a été président
de la république il a un statut à part
et puis nécessairement au dessus de la
mêlée ça ne nage pas françois hollande
par exemple a exprimé son soutien à anne
hidalgo oui et d'ailleurs avec un succès
contre qu'on peut discuter moi je suis
très heureux que nicolas sarkozy ne se
comporte pas aussi médiocrement que
françois hollande est d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre l'un et l'autre mais
pour ce qui est de nicolas sarkozy il a
été le fondateur des républicains
nicolas sarkozy c'est un homme de
fidélité d'immenses fidélité et je sais
que le jour venu le moment venu il ne
manquera pas à l'appel parce qu'il n'a
jamais manqué à l'appel de sa famille
politique on va parler du reste de
l'actualité aujourd'hui cette
mobilisation dans le monde de la justice
un mobilisation inédite le monde de la
justice qui demande plus de moyens qui
dénonce ses conditions de travail jean
castex a dans votre région jeudi pour
les états généraux de la justice est ce
que vous comprenez cette mobilisation
alors que le gouvernement a augmenté le
budget de la justice depuis deux ans oui
parce que le sujet n'est pas qu'une
affaire de moyens et d'ailleurs je n'ai
probable que ce que je dise soit en
désaccord avec les magistrats qui sont
mobilisés mais le coeur de la justice
c'est quoi le coeur de la justice et
c'est l'application des peines plus tôt
la non-application des peines rendez
vous compte aujourd'hui que près de 46%
des peines fermes prononcées ne sont pas
exécutées six mois après qu'elle ait été
prononcé c'est ça le drame de la justice
aujourd'hui c'est pas le drame des
moyens pas seulement c'est un sujet mais
pas seulement et des moyens pour quoi
faire des moyens pour appliquer les
peines et c'est là que le garde des
sceaux le président de la république et
le premier ministre sont totalement
absents il joue les petits comptables
ils ont le sentiment qu'en faisant des
cadeaux budgétaire il règle tout le
problème non ça ne suffira jamais
prenons un autre exemple qui sut des
violences conjugales sur lequel j'ai
beaucoup travaillé on a donné quelques
moyens on a fait voter une loi je les
fait voter sur le bracelet anti
rapprochement mais il nous manque une
autre volonté qui est la création d'une
juridiction spécialisée et ça c'est une
question de volonté politique
d'organisation de réorganisation de la
justice et vous voyez bien que emmanuel
macron ans jean castex où le garde des
sceaux fonctionnent comme des
apothicaires sur ce sujet alors alors
que là nous avons besoin de remettre de
2,2 de cheval sur la question de la
justice voilà pourquoi la confiance est
plus installer puis j'ajoute que pour ce
qui est de garde des sceaux qu'on peut
être un très bon avocat et être mauvais
ministre de la justice c'est
probablement ce que nous constatons
aujourd'hui la question pourquoi votre
question oui gérald darmanin annoncé
hier soir avant en clash et la fermeture
de la mosquée de bové 1/4 l'imam a tenu
des propos incitant à la haine est-ce
que vous saluer cette décision et est-ce
que vous reconnaissez là pour le coup la
fermeté du gouvernement il était
absolument nécessaire de fermer cette
mosquée mais il faut être précis
fermeture temporaire et c'est là que
j'ai eu des désaccords nous avons
aujourd'hui le ministre l'intérieur en
convient lui-même une centaine de
mosquées dites salafis selon le prix
sept ont été fermées pour certaines
seulement temporairement
et je considère que les sens aurait dû
être fermée c'est la proposition nous
faisons chez les républicains
mais en l'occurrence sur des fermetures
définitives nous ne sommes pas à ce
chiffre là et pour moi je suis
absolument convaincu que les fermetures
temporaires n'ont pas de sens quand on
va contre les valeurs de la république
quand on prêche la haine il n'y a pas de
seconde chance ces mosquées là doivent
être fermes et en ont pas temporairement
mais définitivement et c'est aujourd'hui
une faiblesse
dernière question oui dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi un texte d'urgence
importés par un député lrm a été votée a
été votée à l'assemblée qui protège un
petit peu les agriculteurs contre les
appétits des sociétés d'investissement
et qui protègent les terres agricoles
est-ce que penser que c'est un bon texte
est ce que vous en pensez sur la
préservation des terres agricoles c'est
un sujet absolument stratégique nous
perdons à vitesse grand v des terres
agricoles au profil d'urbanisme
notamment les élus locaux ont fait
beaucoup de travail notamment dans les
plans locaux d'urbanisme et ça ne suffit
pas nous devons redevenir la grande
patrie de l'agriculture et la production
agricole et ça passe par la préservation
des terres des terres agricoles et donc
cela leur permet je suis pas sûr qu'ils
permettent tout en tous les cas c'est
une première piste et tout ce qui va
dans le bon sens je le soutiendrai
parlons d'un autre sujet qui est celui
du revenu agricole pouvait demain
permettre à nos agriculteurs d'avoir
accès aux terres c'est essentiel c'est
leur outil de travail mais vous ne
pourrez pas demain redresser notre pays
d'un point de vue agricole si vous ne
traitez pas la question du revenu
agricole
rappelons que notre pays qui a été
pendant des décennies un grand pays
agricole a aujourd'hui une balance
commerciale déficitaire c'est dire que
nous importons plus de produits
agricoles si on sort les vins et
spiritueux que nous en exportons le
traitent le problème bien venu on le
traite par le revenu et par des règles
beaucoup plus strictes que ce qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui avec notamment la
grande distribution les règles
d'incitation de dialogue qui ont été
préconisées par le gouvernement depuis
plusieurs années avec la grande
distribution ne fonctionne pas il faut
des gens mais un gendarme des marges et
des prix qui soit capable de préserver
les prix agricoles de la spéculation
ims ça veut dire que les deux langues à
la maison servait à rien elles n'ont pas
fonctionné sur cette question là
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a en convient
lui-même et nous l'avions dit dès le
début en disant que s'il n'y avait pas
un gendarme qui puisse clairement imposé
les choses nous ne pourrions pas avancer
je le dis la question du revenu agricole
du prix agricoles n'est pas une question
comme les autres moi je fais partie de
ce gaulliste qui considère qu'on ne peut
pas spéculer sur tout et on ne peut pas
spéculer sur les prix agricoles on ne
devrait pas pouvoir le faire avec le
risque que cela se répercute sur les
prix à la consommation
mais le premier risque c'est que ce soit
l'inflation aujourd'hui touchent tout le
oui mais c'est le premier risque c'est
que ça se répercute sur les marges de la
grande distribution et pour moi ça c'est
pas un risque c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle merci aux conversations radio
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]